[Applause]
[Music]
Latin America is perhaps the region with
the least military ambition in the world
[Music]
the government spends relatively little
on defense and in general with some
exceptions creating large and powerful
armies is not exactly a priority
[Music]
just like this the subject of the Armed
Forces has been very controversial in
the region in recent years and there's
no wonder because the second half of the
20th century wasn't exactly a quiet time
for Latin America throughout this period
and especially in the 1960s and 1970s
this region was one of the territories
in the world which was the most affected
by military force
[Music]
Papa's our Mara from consciente de la
manna to drop area reality
[Music]
for these years practically every
country in the region participated in
what kind of became a macabre tradition
of Coos military groups and of course
plenty of repression for example let's
take a look at 1978
[Music]
or a toccata no I wound on it supplier
while we're not Ian for parole
[Applause]
in that year among other countries
Argentina Bolivia Brazil Chile Ecuador
Paraguay Peru Cuba Nicaragua Honduras El
Salvador Panama and even the peaceful
Uruguay were under a military
dictatorship and do forgive me if I left
anything out because I see it's a pretty
long list dictators of every kind
existed left-right pro-us anti-us harder
softer but well they all have one common
elements and that was repression
yeah in the framework of the Cold War
and bloc struggles many of these
dictatorships they were supported by the
United States under the framework of
what was later known as Operation Condor
a sinister intelligence collaboration
plan forged between the military
dictatorships of Adela's Argentina
Pinochet's Chile Alfredo Stroessner --zz
Paraguay
jawoll Figueredo Brazil and border
berries Uruguay they were all aided by
the CIA in order to achieve a single
objective persecute and annihilate the
political opposition especially the
leftist groups that were supported by
the Soviet regime and of course as you
might expect the dictatorships forged
under the other political color they
weren't any better not at all in fact
considering this it isn't hard to
imagine why the Armed Forces issue has
been so controversial well more than 30
years have now passed since this dark
period and in this video we're going to
be answering several questions what is
the current state of Latin America's
armies what functions do they really
have and do they pose any risks to the
democracy and freedom of these countries
well let's dive in armies in Latin
America before we begin and just out of
curiosity well let me ask you a question
which do you think are the strongest
most powerful armies in Latin America
well this is always quite subjective but
according to the global firepower index
from 2017 which is an indicator that
attempts to measure which armies are
more powerful and to different
parameters these are the top five in
Latin America first place Noorie
surprising it goes to Brazil which is
the greatest regional power this is
followed by in this order Mexico
Argentina Peru and Colombia the truth is
that Latin America is the region with
the smallest of budget dedicated to
defense in 2016 it was just over 1% of
its GDP which is about a sixty seven
billion dollars this expenditure is much
lower than the global average
especially because Latin American armies
tend to have a quite a high number of
soldiers
[Music]
to get an idea in total the region has
over 1.7 3 million soldiers and of
course the combination of a low budget
with many soldiers needs two outdated
armies with plenty of operational
problems let's take a look at the most
important army the brazilian army brazil
spends twenty three point seven billion
dollars every year which kind of on the
face of it seems like quite a lot right
well the problem is that the army has
three hundred and forty thousand
soldiers which means that three-quarters
of the budget goes to salaries and to
pensions if to this we add basic
supplies then the money left for
equipment is very very low and in the
rest of Latin America ratio is a similar
on average 70% of the money goes
directly to salaries in other words
Latin American armies usually have a lot
of soldiers and very little equipment
looking inwards so if we talk about
armies wars and conflicts between
countries we could say that Latin
America is one of the most peaceful
regions in the world the last armed
conflict occurred in 1995 and what was
later known as the synapomorphy dorans
Peru but no formal declaration of war
was ever made since then the trend has
begun that has made Latin America a
benchmark every time there is a conflict
between two countries instead of
threatening each other with bombs and
cannons those involved resorts to
international justice this is what is
currently happening for example with the
conflicts between Bolivia and Chile over
the sea fronts may conflict that is
being resolved at the International
Court of Justice in The Hague Bolivia
replies to the lawsuit against Chile at
The Hague Court for sea access however
internally well things they are
completely different we could say that
Latin America has the record for being
the most peaceful region and at the same
time the most violence once
[Music]
what I mean here is that between
countries there is no serious threat of
war but the situation is different if we
talk about internal violence more
incredible than that though is the fact
that one in three homicides that occur
every year globally take place in Latin
America so because apparently all
enemies are at home Latin American
military forces focus on at home tasks
such as confronting guerillas drug
traffickers or just dealing with
violence in general in fact in the
region it is becoming increasingly
common for military forces to replace
the police in security and surveillance
tasks the paalam him is that evidence
shows that soldiers aren't really good
at playing the role of the police
[Music]
the insufficient solution
contrary it's what we might think at
first crime rates in Brazil or Mexico
far from decreasing have increased since
soldiers began participating in citizen
security in fact the five most dangerous
cities in the world Caracas Acapulco San
Pedro Sula Central District and Victoria
have a military presence and swamp
that's not all
[Music]
power abuse extrajudicial detentions or
collateral victims have also increased
with military presence which further
favors and feeds a culture of violence
this is something that is unfortunately
far too widespread in the region
nowadays
the thing is that soldiers are forces
trained for war in order to eliminate
the enemy not to impose order and the
rule of law to achieve rule of law what
is needed a detectives courts judges
local police forces and even citizen
collaboration not the military we can
take a look at what has happened for
example in Mexico
[Music]
as soon as he became president in
December 2006 Felipe Calderon declared
war on drugs and placed the army on the
streets since then not only has
narcotics trafficking not decreased but
homicide rates of triples the army it's
simply not enough they can of course
lend a hand in very serious cases but
they cannot be a police force it just
doesn't work and yes I do know that
corruption in the police is a problem
but this isn't simply fixed by resorting
to using the army and indeed this
actually leads to two other major
problems the first one is political risk
so consider this Madden America's armed
forces must be anti-imperialist Evo
Morales well what do you want me to say
to me seeing politicians use military
forces to defend their political ideas
whatever they might be seems very very
dangerous using that power of force is
always going to be super tempting this
is what has happened for example in
Venezuela where the armed forces have
pretty much become something like a
Praetorian Guard for Nicolas Maduro as
Bolivarian regime
[Music]
and if that wasn't enough there is also
the big corruption problem see the
military industry is really opaque and
it's got huge contracts which are two
pretty basic ingredients for corruption
just have a look what happens in 2010 in
the dominican republic in 2010 a major
corruption scandal affected the
dominican armed forces due to the
fraudulent purchase of eight super
tucano
as aircraft from the brazilian company
Embraer it is suspected that 87 million
dollars remained in the hands of members
of the country's political and military
hierarchy Lilian babay a professor at
Bentley University in Massachusetts and
that's just one example and it's not
even the most important one so taking
all of this into account maybe it would
be a good idea to consider some sort of
military alliance
[Music]
a latin-american NATO now allow me to
propose an idea that may seem just the
touch crazy now based on what we've just
discussed wouldn't it be a good idea to
think about building a great military
alliance an alliance in which different
countries could organize and provide
different units and bodies for different
types of tasks this would have several
major advantages the one military
influence over political power would
decrease and sovereignty would be
guaranteed for all countries in addition
and if necessary during natural
disasters Latin American countries could
have an army that could deploy rapidly
where they are needed
it could also push for much-needed Latin
American integration and to increase
this region's role in the world of
politics
[Music]
but above all it would free many
resources both economic and human and
this could be used to promote citizen
security and reduce violence rates in
these countries in a way the European
Union they're actually trying to do
something similar so while it may sound
like a bit of a crazy idea at first
maybe it's not like crazy after all
for example Costa Rica suppressed its
army decades ago and the results in
terms of security have been better than
those of its neighbors we've said before
here on visual politic that the 21st
century is going to be India's century
and probably China and Asia in general
[Music]
but now we're wondering maybe not in
America too well now you've heard our
opinion here at visual politic and now
it's your turn do you agree that
soldiers can be used to replace the
police for matters of security well do
let us know in the comments section
below also please do like and subscribe
for brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday also do check out our friends
at the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine and as always thank you
for watching
[Music]